[Music]
all right hey and one sec I'm just
getting the links and tweeting outs and
the other things
I'm nourish I don't know why zip it
sorry
never know if you can hear me by the way
I'm using my Yeti microphone so it
should be better audio oh snap gaming
video if you want more gaming videos go
on to gaming with yog monix ah
there's not much up there but there will
be I'm sorry transitioning what am i
doing oh yeah
hey beefy luck what now
anyway I keep getting distracted but
where is the freaking way where is the
link I don't understand
I always do this
[Music]
[Music]
okay here's the link
do
life is strange life is strange like the
street
sweet dad
oh that means it's at my house mates
know that I'm streaming so they won't
come it
go
okay I'm back with you thanks for being
patient although I wasn't supposed to
stream until 9:00 but I'm not kidding
University it's like killing me but I
figured I just need to get back into
this live streaming thing I haven't done
it for so long now just a thought if
it's like oh god but I think if I just
try and do this like even just for an
hour I just tell myself and to break
from my uni work I got this because
listen I used to have a break and I want
to play a games so why not it makes
sense right Amen sister yeah coffee I
published the game that I was making
with Tabitha and Tiffany the two girls
that go to uni with finally publish that
sleep paralysis game I don't know how
many of you have been here for a while
but we were making it in second year
because this is fair dear computer game
arts and it's now up on Google Play
Store so you can freakin play the game
I'm so excited it took me so long to get
a game up there as well I had to like
make relevant information and make sure
it was certified it's Peggy twelve by
the way yeah I'm pretty excited I put up
a video on gaming with yogaman X that's
a trailer for it so you can go check
that out if you want to but I think
tomorrow
I don't know whenever I have time I've
nearly finished editing a video that
includes the trailer but also just
includes me can i rambling about it and
offering you free codes to get the game
for free it's only 70 P but I figured I
would give you some fruit codes because
you know I'm nice like that
so yeah
I mean I usually wait but I really just
want to play can i play
another thing is I will actually make my
first game of this not private because I
was gonna re-upload it but let's just
take it too long I'd rather make new
content then re-upload a video that had
already livestream so let's make this
public so everyone can see it
because people be like why are you
playing episode 2 if you never played
episode 1 it's like why did I just live
streamed it but that may be a public way
it's less public now
okay
good to see a stream going yes TSS
trying to get back on this trying to
make it a fun thing not an intimidating
thing I've been that in that frame of
mind recently where everything is
intimidating and I'm like I can't do it
because like I feel like everything has
to be perfect like right now my my
lighting is not perfect and I don't have
an external camera going and I'm not
going to free up load this but I just
realized I've been taking everything
everything in my life way too seriously
and there's like no fun in it anymore so
I have to put effort in to make it fun
that sounds really boring doesn't it but
yeah I'm gonna just start having fun
with it instead of worrying so much
because I'm still in uni so you know uni
comes fresh and ya have a lot of
realizations recently a lot of hard
talking's - talking's do that work
thanks mr. t latency most of you just
like happy when I pop up anyway I'm sure
you guys would be happier if I was like
actually here every week than if I was
here once a month and then I reapplied
at that video on higher quality
like that's not what YouTube is about I
don't want to be like oh no I do wanna
my contents be really good fun you know
yeah
anyway [ __ ] cuz I'll go on this pages
I've just my head has been like in bits
about all this recently it smell really
bad
so we'll see I just stopped taking
myself so seriously but I still want to
make really good content um I don't
think I can settle for like a video a
week if it's gonna be crap I can try and
make a video a week but if I'm not happy
with the video it's not going up just so
it is gonna be and I'm gonna have to
just be okay with that
so then make a video every week but
perhaps the quality's not very good or
sacrifice one every now and then and
make sure that everybody I put up I am
super proud of and I think I have to do
the second one because even if I try to
do the first one I can't allow myself to
do it I literally I go sometimes to let
export a video that I know I'm not happy
with yet and then I just can I stay up
all night thinking about it and I'm like
no other video blog gondola so they end
up just making you better anyway
alright shut up let's let's play the
game
what okay I was like doesn't make for
them three as well that's not it's just
- okay so let's start episode two
everyone say hi to chip Becca father it
was like sterling no do you not get me I
always make words up screaming a ling a
ling Aling
Picchu your Nez I don't think that's a
nice shirt you know it's Jimmy Lee
hailey Persinger legging
I can't believe firelock is playing a
show in the old mill I'm gonna teach
this little punk some manners hey DK get
the [ __ ] out of here
between your grades and your disregard
for my rules
hey look guys hey I - guys I'm worried
we don't have to like each other but you
will respect me
hello black cow hey do you know Rachel's
a dragon how would you like to join me
don't be surprised it's such a pretty
game as well and it's makes you dizzy
which makes me happy that was my dad I'm
developing in like we can make our game
this pretty
oh yeah this thing
[Music]
I've had so many conversations about the
ending of that cuz I was totally
oblivious and I was just like oh she's
very angry and this fire girl never was
like yeah but did she not make the fire
all my fault you don't get him out but
maybe she did I don't know anyway
miss price how good of you to join us
I'm so sorry we're late
my shift ran late at the diner and then
just sorry okay let us proceed one of
you here is new to the Blackwell
disciplinary process and the other is
all too familiar with it Blackwell's
code of conduct is built upon a
foundation of mutual respect meant to
foster an environment conducive to
education and enrichment when that
respect violated reality check time
yesterday did actually happen I ditch
school with Rachel amber and then Rachel
really did start that fire and that was
after we actually agreed to run away
from here right are you paying attention
to me Chloe what miss price the last
time we met an agreement was brokered do
you recall what that was I know I know
no let me refresh your memory we agreed
that you would rededicate yourself to
becoming an exemplary Blackwell citizen
we did in the event that you were unable
we also agree reassess your future
status at the academy despite all this
you engaged in the following actions
yesterday in subordinate language
attempting to sabotage the academic
goals of one of our top students
Victoria chase
yeah she cheated she was at school doing
her own homework because I thought
Blackwell had a zero tolerance policy on
plagiarism excellent suggestion
stricter punishment for students who
violate Blackwell's code of conduct is
next on our agenda now hold on
why is Chloe being punished for someone
else's plagiarism the infraction
involved both students Victoria will be
reprimanded as well Yeah right
Yeah right back for her plagiarism miss
chase might have been suspended might
have if mr. Prescott Nathan Prescott
hadn't spoken to me on Victoria's behalf
and we have witnesses saying miss price
was also involved in a bullying incident
of the same mr. Prescott I was helping
that situation I stood up for that
little you know I suppose that's she's
not helping yourself it's say what you
will about my daughter but she is not a
bully
maybe yeah you see my room instead of me
you know the guy who actually did what
you're accusing me of mr. North's
[Music]
handled separately and Chloe's situation
is less sensitive hey Dad hey hero time
hey guys situations we are here to
discuss your daughter and her actions
convenient
ah my mom comes first in every situation
this is all [ __ ] right I'm beginning
to suspect that myself I am sorry you
feel that way
but your daughter's misbehavior is real
and serious and yet even with your
prodigious disciplinary record miss
price we needn't discuss any of it we
needn't know because you severed your
relationship with Blackwell the minute
you left school grounds without
permission what does that mean it means
you forced my hand this is a consequence
of your actions Chloe I have no choice
but to do it what what what what
yesterday was all me my idea I was
having a bad day I needed to blow off
some steam and I took it too far
Chloe tried to talk me out of it I've
been down that road she told me you're
better than this but I wouldn't listen
see Chloe was afraid I'd get in trouble
or hurt so she came with me but only to
keep me safe I'm just sorry that you
allowed me to drag you down to my level
can you forgive me for what for what you
didn't do anything your willingness to
stand by me even now it's truely and
she's good Chloe is this true it's true
totally not true she really is an
amazing actress miss price
oh I mean mmm
I mmm I didn't want to get her in
trouble but she obviously is cool with
this cuz I
she kind of did though it was her I was
gonna go to class yeah fine fine yes it
was her idea but it's no I feel bad we
were in it together yeah yeah miss amber
based on what you've just told me I have
grounds to punish you are you sure what
you've told me is the truth yes this
can't be the full story
Rachel shut up here we saw you cheat on
her miss amber you're sure Chloe price
didn't coerce you or coerce her I'm just
trying to get to the bottom of why
someone like us they keep the amazake
Rachel not my daughter excuse me do you
have a list of students you assume the
worst about let's enjoy the show have no
right to treat Chloe this way this is
because she's on financial aid isn't it
let's all just calm down after
everything we she's been through in the
last two years you should be ashamed of
yourself
miss price mom mrs. price mrs. price I
appreciate your position but I assure
you it is only your daughter's past
behavior that has led us here today
I understand mr. wells there is no doubt
that Chloe's behavior must improve but
given what we've just learned about the
negative influence she was under I hope
you will allow her just one more chance
miss amber I am as surprised as I am
disappointed in you I understand this
being your first infraction in no way
reduces its severity still we will not
be suspending you at this time good
but you've squandered our you will no
longer be my administrative assistant
first period and you will no longer be
involved in Blackwell's performance of
The Tempest
oh I'm so sorry what are you insane
she's the only one who can play it
pending miss price right she loves that
show since this is her first infraction
mr. Hamburg yeah I don't tell you how to
run the District Attorney's Office
please don't tell me how to run my
school there's a reason we have
understudies for all circumstances
accidental and deliberate I'm sure your
understudy Victoria chase how fitting
yes I'm sure Victoria Chase will do fine
you mad miss price
Chloe is upset for her friend but we are
both grateful that she is not going to
be unduly blamed for what happened there
is plenty of blame to go around
Chloe's future at blackwell will be
discussed next unless you had something
to add first miss price
let's do this Rachel missing the play
for me but thanks to her acting skills
I'll have to go down in flames if I want
to fix this okay let's dude is your head
out of your ass Welles
you seriously think yesterday was a
little Miss Sunshine's idea miss amber
has accepted her responsibility I hope
you have the slightest idea how this
works you don't wake up one morning and
decide to be an outlaw
you need priors you need training Rachel
confessed are you calling her a liar
mm I confess to thinking she can act
like a [ __ ] she can't act just
bought her crap hook line and sinker you
don't have to do this it's okay really
uh you don't tell me what to tell me
what to do do it's not what you're doing
sycophants I'm a lone wolf and you're
Little Red Riding Hood
welcome to grandmother's house [ __ ] ah
Chloe this can't be you apologize this
instant
hell no Rachel out of class
I couldn't wrong I couldn't be mean what
I would have gone it alone okay go my
child I speak up miss price your words
do not exonerate Rachel but they do
further implicate you
this is my swan song my farewell to
black hell I'm only sorry I had but one
[ __ ] off to give I've heard enough
you were clearly trying to cover for
your classmate
I appreciate the motive but I appreciate
honesty more is that understood
yes sir you will not be removed from the
plate was that so hard
thank you and miss price I came into
today's meeting
planning to suspend you for the rest of
the school year with the chance for you
no I didn't fail that one I want it and
now you are expelled she wanted to get
expelled but does she like sweet get
Matthews make sure it's not Locker you
may wait outside my office until he
arrives it's what you do what you're
like good day mrs. price mr. and mrs.
ambough from school no maybe no don't do
that
come on Chloe
I'm sorry nothing to be sorry about meet
me at the junkyard later you got I
didn't get the chance to introduce
myself I'm Joyce mrs. price
I'm rose this is James I'm sorry we had
to meet like this no I'm sorry I'm sure
for you this is an unusual circumstance
we really should be going
nice to meet you hey Bobo mom he has
coordinates working what hey Chloe I'm
supposed to walk you out just you know
badass hey skip you know I was supposed
to have today off right sorry that my
totally fair and impartial hearing and
convenience to you man
I don't really care about any of this
[ __ ]
except my secret stash might as well
grab my emergency joint while I'm here
uh what about this though you need your
cat but I'll see you up love how every
time someone tells me how much potential
I have it's right before saying how I'm
wasting it all you have better than this
let's put this in the trash will clear
up properly [ __ ] this planet yes I agree
I had big plans for adding to this
collage oh well do it at home instead
so this is interesting they attend
almost now we understand how she got
kicked out key keeper of my graffiti
pants you've served me well gonna cat
that she likes chemistry she's not that
one either
oh no she doesn't carry English but they
absolutely positively the best concert
of 2008 too bad it's time to go mega cab
semi is hot
it's good thing she's right brother Ben
what's that Oh
she kept that hidden like ready while
jackpot wait what the hell
enjoy your faith Michael hey Tristan
Chloe hey Oh had to borrow your stash ah
desperate times you know I promise I'll
get you back next week I won't be here
next week
just den like every inch of this place I
wish I could tag it from floor to
ceiling
but with skip watching me bathroom
then I'm out cool okay but try to make
it fast will you
is it like after-school time now I think
it is no all they're in class hey I know
this bathroom
[Music]
[Music]
she's such a badass graffiti with
drilling it's good
should've been an artist
hey Yakima fan
[Music]
lovely music in this game I still listen
to the soundtrack from the past
she's literally Brittany fruits from
every Oh
[Music]
yeah appreciate it art
very true boo boo it's a good pen didn't
run out of ink and it literally wrote
easily everywhere on every type of
surface that market thick quiet lining
gaming greetings
your new oh thank you
thank you for being a new person and
welcome later skip later my skip haven't
eaten skips in a long time
crisps my tongue and just leave them I
got text well blows that meeting hello
sucks you're hella weird you are
seriously look Oh what seriously it's
okay yesterday was worth it
of course it was I've got I've got a
bunch of messages and please utilize
caution while traveling to from yeah
whatever uh this all the fire can go
down Elliot
[Music]
after the tempest you Anaheim oh yeah my
still gonna go see it with Elliott I
didn't um Chloe you can't keep doing
this to me I'm trying my best
sorry max would have loved this [ __ ]
it's just what max does oh noes only
though she does come back this will do
you know right now anyway well this car
crushing spirits must pay pretty well
this taking pride and block well look
like he's not taking pride in yourself
ah so the trustees and there are
enormous bank accounts
Andy in there nope nope listen yet maybe
they'll use my scholarship money to
finally fix this pothole at bucks why
are you looking at night or I needed to
bum one no one here smokes [ __ ] this
place oh I knew that big repeat thing
around that hmm what could the tempest
use more of an icky all that's left is
to get arrested it's a sasquatch it's
chewy
I have friends oh like Jim bought up
some black beautiful
well done Chloe keep up the drawing
skills I'm sure will come in handy
I guess this fire is no joke still can't
believe Rachel started it I know hey hey
Elliot what brings Chloe price to school
on a Saturday morning nothing good I bet
I was expelled wait really
holy [ __ ] I know I'm surprised it took
this long - do you want a hug does she
want a hug
no she's a Chloe price big deal out of
this oh sorry
oh yeah he's yeah the love interest nah
who's Rachel I ever gonna Bob yeah and
let me guess did she get off scot-free
well yeah but she tried to cover for me
uh-huh anyway what are you doing here I
thought I should come early to grab
tickets for The Tempest you said we
might see it together
nice huh right good call
did you get my text about hanging out
afterwards
Oh Elliott ah we can hang out as friends
I mean I'm not really big on making
plans but maybe cool cool sounds sounds
good I better go
my mom is waiting to SiC her attack
mustache on me
her boyfriend don't worry about it see
you around w when is The Tempest yeah
later Sunday right was it tonight IV was
tonight wasn't it Alamelu Oh what's this
so look at the stick hair look at all
the things my other vehicle is drama
lamb
someone's trying a bit too hard with
those bumper stickers Satan's baby
momma's ears that's what they do best
hear it black well empty things out and
toss them aside it's about damn tongue
oh here we go
argument Chloe your mother and I have
been talking please do this later I
don't think I can handle another fight
right now and who do you expect to
handle things for you your mother I
don't need a conversation not with
sergeant asshat here hi Kyle our times
that's my mother Carla sorry I can't do
your cauliflower
um I don't know why he just said so just
say she's my mother
if my mother has something to say she
we'll say it to me she has the problem
is you don't listen maybe if you try
listening to me instead of fighting me
about everything you might actually
learn a thing or two
what like how to have no job or how to
be a soldier soldiers put family and
future above self and now getting kicked
out of school
that's what losers do you had a
scholarship Chloe do you know what that
means what kind of opportunity you gave
up do you want to work at the diner
someone needed my hot one needed my help
who your friend Rachel because I think
the daughter of the DA is going to be
just fine I need your help me your
mother we need to get our own house in
order right now what I need most of all
is for the two of you to start getting
along Chloe I care about hey Peter thank
you something I'm willing to forget even
for them incident yesterday if you
improve your attitude going forward
incident it's not Paige what incident
Chloe was incredibly out of line she
insulted me hey wait I said thank you
for the lift didn't I but with an
apology I'm willing to start over
buying here of time thanks for coming ah
fine just for my mom reset button
pressed I am glad to hear it from now on
I will be assisting your mother in a few
areas like making sure that you are no
longer abusing drugs or alcohol
mom Chloe I'd like you to empty your
pockets and place all your belongings on
the trunk of the car what the [ __ ] was a
good thing she didn't have that you are
not abusing drugs if you're not you
should be eager for the chance to prove
it mom she doesn't have anything on her
so right you I need my mom I know Chloe
and I'm sorry but David feel Joyce we
feel this is the best way to start fresh
let's go Chloe quit stallin tonight
pockets there's nothing in there right
you have nothing that okay I think she
has [ __ ] so badly she might have a
lighter and a pen hey good pen lighter
cigarettes and a cat picture iPhone cute
keys that's it no weed cuz she got
annoyed so I thought you had no weed
thank you so much to breeze with my
files I appreciate that have a song teal
game last night video yeah no I actually
googled it you Cleveland i YouTubed it
and I didn't find inning of a new
chapter for us maybe she has the one
ring in there a new holder one that will
involve the three of us together all get
high together talk away probably the
best thing for everyone at this stage is
for me to move in Chloe after everything
that's happened I'm at a loss
oh no exactly we need a firmer hand
stewardship talk to me most kids don't
get healing a choice to have a say when
a stepparent moves in to be fair you're
trying I get it
I swear I do and I've been making it
harder for you but this is not the
answer it's the only answer I have Chloe
let me save this channel again every
years I never thought you'd choose David
over me
oh I don't say that Chloe sorry I took
that for curry okay I'm not anyone over
anyone else it's about the three of us
having a home together it'll be better
than you think Chloe once everything's
running smoothly you'll see what a
stable home can be like he acts as if
she never used to have a dad that's what
irritates me
a paint job so messy
it's okay you're gonna go and see Rachel
tonight oh there is no home not if he's
there Chloe let her go so much for the
reset button as soon as her tantrum is
over
he constantly sounds so entitled yeah
cookie was in the forces oh yeah I just
hate how he acts as if Chloe's never had
a dad that's just it's just so
insensitive
you should understand that you're never
gonna replace the dad thanks s2 back
snarfer doodle how do you know which way
is up when your whole life has been
turned upside down
where she she in the junkyard
[Music]
yeah
that chord progression kind of sounded
like sweater I can't go home anymore
[Music]
is this junkyard all I've got left
[Music]
now you have your mom like she's trying
I get it she's gone through laughs
I hope you had a good breakfast zipser
[Music]
why does she is it
she's gonna fix it
I've been very impressive she fixes that
this thing is a mess but maybe I can fix
it if this beast will ever run again the
first thing it needs is what what a new
battery ok my exbest friend
extraordinaire
it's artsy [ __ ] loves
photography mother life had suffered
definitely more than me oh my god Oh sad
oh I still miss her if she came back
tomorrow I said hey Cleo you want to
dress up like pirates and peace to be
together I take it back in a heartbeat
that is so cute
it's very sad ok I won't cry I cry all
the time and everything I guess so
crying so much
ok I thought I had a message
maybe I need my daughter back coming can
you just forget about David for a second
think about me maybe I just see space
maybe that's cute
oh I feel kind of sorry for her monks I
know she's just trying to do her best
get battery put in truck guess I was
pretty pissed at Rachel last night
amazing that someone I just met could
have made me this angry intense feelings
happens when you least expect it maybe
it's in the school bus I guess I'll
never ride one of these again that's so
awesome why would a factory be no and
Abby's show a long way from the beach I
always wanted a pet snake instead I got
David [ __ ] everything I have new
followers smartparker followers on what
like places I'm confused
thank you
if we pay guardians of the galaxy the
tell-tale series no I haven't played
much the telltale games to be honest
with you
Wow shitty ride drug dealer
hey bird oh here we go
got you right under there good oh I
can't open it
oh okay
yeah got ourselves a better read oh you
can follow anyone your friends this
thanks for let me now to breeze noise
syringe castle that of Arcadia Bay they
don't put on the postcards it's down
here's anyway after me to graffiti still
love opening up the diner with Mama for
school
I guess those days are now officially
over all the whales came up dead what a
sentence that was pretty cool five the
first game that I think this mat has
seen some things mostly feet well yes
but welcome mats genuinely four feet
okay I don't think there's any no
there's nothing for me to do you don't
think at least
this chunky art is impassive I'll
explore more after I talk
hmm we know yak - a whale yes I do
foreshadowing for shauna in what oh look
a so you can play the evil within - hell
yes I am live streaming the evil within
- on Halloween
Tuesday see you then I'm gonna
livestream it with my game deaf girls
the girls that I'm making the games with
so it's gonna be a good one look out for
that
that's my following noises Halloween
stream hi yeah this thing you look likes
plenty more love than I can give right
now yeah you don't have much time to new
toilets we all sit up a bit
hey Richard are you coming
Chloe price Rachel amber I don't suck
already really don't wait what why is
she saying she sucks what my mom thinks
I do don't know if I can stand going
home tonight still that got me something
from home then I'll meet you jump guard
see already seen you better I'm awaiting
rusted floorboard probably a good idea
to cover over this with something what
like what what are you what are you
talking about what are you why are you
doing this up I'm too confused you turn
this into like a little are you making a
den for Rachel oh that's so cute
hope I can put in here oh we saw a light
both okay let's go and get the UM while
an escape hatch couldn't be nice oh
she's actually making advances yeah okay
I know it's get I think I don't know
what to put over the hole actually maybe
the mannequin okay let's see what I know
we can use the beach towel and stuff I
haven't really looked around here so
maybe I can do something here no not
going over there oh oh that's dad's car
okay well that's a bit awkward um what's
this Oh climb up the boat hell yeah
don't tip it over
Chloe and what are you doing come on use
our buy strength damn you cigarettes now
you just need to do more push-ups and
planks but mainly push-ups and pull-ups
do you even lift bro
[Music]
thanks to the primary rival will I be
dressed as Chewbacca Halloween yeah
that's a good idea
oh nice music I should definitely get
dressed up the best string higher flag
this might make the perfect cover for
that tone seat
okay so wasn't living so nine years and
I put the bass challenge Hey look at
this
okay I'm still looking but it's only
because I'm so fixated but yeah weird it
is by Tabriz thank you for coming have a
good piece can I go over I'm here
oh wait something yeah what's Oh for the
floor or I've got a what around here now
something
where does she put it non-existent
pockets yeah can I go over here
posters no this is a vortex club I
wouldn't mind join it be whoever you
eyes we eat drink and merrily say [ __ ]
after reagan and his oppressive regime
[Music]
cute here's hoping for oh this is like
Oh everything was over here you knew
hey slinky thank you for watching this
stream and welcome can I get inside
there and I don't think so yeah I think
just keeps going I don't need that right
don't want to leave yet
okay I think I've gotten everything
anyway so let's go back to the car
unless I can find something to graffiti
on don't really know why I would look at
glass shots
what's my [ __ ] right okay
sweet so we have all the things to make
the coolest dan from Rachel amber so
when i'm rachel karz sure we'll all
impressed will win her over with our
little truck ten
all we need then is a fire and some
snacks new perfect I want to just take
in the whole oh ya know cuz there's no
plugs up here or anything cool it's so
cute
this thing looks like a rusted-out
shopping cart it probably drives like
one too that's if it ever does Drive
which seems questionable still how sweet
would that be is that Rachel yeah oh hey
Frank what's up really what about Oh
like I'm a junk yard I'm hanging out in
the junkyard
north of town okay and Frank
Braniff aunt is everything cool I'm not
in trouble or anything right those are
money in general or to you
time for a hard-earned smoke break by
the portable Emma I didn't II understand
what you mean that my life is saying
streams have been blocked though yeah I
don't know what you mean by that
hope not but anyway we'll see hmmm what
should we do oh good evening we get one
chance to make a first expression
frightening yes always October
this will give you your about to die
think about from tennis on to is your
truck on wheels I think so
she is so much sure that we can do yeah
[Music]
your life
[Music]
all right the fire is still going
[Music]
[Music]
he find a statue and push it on the dash
for me
[Music]
it's not ready the safest place to fall
asleep but I gather you're probably a
bit bored and overwhelmed a lot of
stuffs happened
oh no don't oh it's night time this is
creepy oh [ __ ] I slept all day but
wouldn't Frank you've come to see well
what the hell
hey Wesker Wesker you'll be glad to know
that on Tuesday I'm doing a Halloween
livestream of the evil within - even
though I haven't finished now she's
dreaming
she is dreaming definitely who's the guy
gonna be Frank
Oh her dad her dad yeah yeah
I wonder if it burned like this the day
the day it happened dad what are we
doing here - eating the mushroom
this is really creepy
let's give the marshmallows a dad now we
gotta put on the fire
amazing isn't it I can't look away sure
don't pretend you're not mesmerized to
see you're so drawn to it you don't even
realize the danger danger fire blinds us
just like darkness but darkness blinds
with absence with loss
what is fire blind with beauty
this is Rachel amber of fire but
sometimes there's a greater beauty yet
to come incredible fire is jealous Chloe
it wants all the beauty for itself
that's why you need to be careful
careful of what
okay that was pretty creepy
she shook II what is this [ __ ] it's
called life is strange you've never
heard of it it's pretty well-known space
it like a telltale game but the first
one you could rewind this one you can't
because you're Chloe hey I never told
you not to fall asleep with a lit
cigarette you could start a fire says
you
so are you gonna invite me in come into
my den I love giving rides to strange
Drifters hop in Thanks
what she brought with them
still doesn't run their dessert damn
you've been busy
it's nothing just some junk I found
lying around pirate flag bright green
lights that is dark too dark
perfect dark Chloe this is incredible I
can't believe you found us an escape
vehicle already unless he's not scared
to run away oh I guess I wasn't thinking
about it that way are you getting cold
feet I thought you were all bye-bye
that's why just go to the bag I still AM
I guess you guess it's not so easy this
truck doesn't even start and we don't
have any money we can figure all of that
out I have no doubt besides there's no
rush true and no Blackwell huh holy [ __ ]
counties and licensed places and Bonnie
a famous super high
that's very cool thank you aiexander he
actually expelled you why not no reason
to prolong the inevitable
it's definitely black you were gonna
yeah better than worry for me was
amazing I don't know how to thank you
whatever you tried to cover for me to
tried and failed I guess we know who the
better liar is or maybe my lie was the
one he wanted to believe at least wells
has no idea what really went down with
us last night
[ __ ] got pretty wild
ah last I checked you're the one who
went all puffs no that's not what I
meant realize well I was angry I didn't
expect the whole stupid park to go woosh
but come on doesn't accomplish sound way
cooler than accessory after the back is
that the official Arcadia Bay DA's
opinion accomplice it is I'd be way
happier going to jail than having to
live at home with dictator David he
announced his plans to move in this
morning Oh Chloe that's awful
I'm so sorry you know we both could use
therapy therapy everyone could use but
there's no kick back in tell me what's
bothering you
that can't be very dog
I guess David there's this dildo with a
moustache who's been dating my mom and
now he thinks he's moving in with us how
do I stop him hmm
that's a hard one I'm not sure there's
really anything you can do then what the
hell am I talking to you for just
because you can't stop him doesn't mean
you don't fight back the resistance
begins now
levers of sauce all right you're going
to need a new nickname to mark your
enemy have you got apparently West's
says the original truck in the well
Chloe's truck in the original life is
strange
so she does get this morning that's very
cool um step do she's step douche
because he's inserting himself where he
doesn't belong also he's a douche I like
it poetic may I also suggest stepladder
why stepladder because he climbs on your
mom every night oh and pretty soon
they'll be stepping down the aisle what
the hell kind of therapist are you sorry
it's called shock therapy highly
controversial
the fire so my new friend who everyone
thinks is perfect it's something that
[ __ ] [ __ ] meth so last night what do
I do this perfect friend of yours who
I'm assuming is also an exceptional
beauty sounds like she may have been
inspired by someone new in her life
someone who was just lay beyond Chloe
had a knockout in the looks department
wow that makes it all better
perhaps this friend of yours who I
reiterate must be just stunning I needed
someone in her life to teach her how to
steal wine from yuppie picnickers how
not to give a [ __ ] because she was tired
of having to give so many [ __ ] all the
time oh I know what you mean that makes
sense right well I've been booted from
school and I'm not entirely sure what to
do about it
you mean how to cope with your feelings
of anger and disappointment no I mean
how to express my feelings of intense
joy uh-huh
do you think you might be taking this a
little too well you tell me
well-adjusted I'd bet my therapist's
license that no one's ever called you
that before
Touche doc all right actually somewhat
therapeutic thank you now you come over
here sit on my lap for the mind of Chloe
price and now it's your turn tell me all
about what it's like being daughter of
Arcadia Bay's most famous scumbag
it sucks to blunt sorry I do that
sometimes
nah I'm just I don't know tell me can we
talk about something else I told you my
Star Wars hi she's so mysterious mr.
what the five Hey
chances are pretty soon this entire town
will be burnt to a smoldering pile of
ashes so you know things are really
looking up for us from what I've tasted
of desire I hold with those who favor
fire
you are my fire Rachel amber apparently
I don't know I think that's what I had
down please do you want to say there's a
point when you've been acting so much
that you don't even have your own
personality anymore you're just whatever
you think other people want you to be I
think that a personality I wasn't
talking about you never Watson so much
like Hermione Granger it's crazy really
exist you saw him in Wales his office
the whole thing is a performance and now
I'm starting to feel like everything in
my life is [ __ ]
he stole my dad how can I make sure I
don't end up like him hmm
you just you don't be like him
even if you wanted to you're too awesome
the fact that you believe that makes me
feel better
[ __ ] it's time for the play as if my
life didn't have enough drama in it
good luck you know it's nice to come
here fast look before show it's bad luck
how is challenging right good luck bad
luck you're supposed to say break leg
that's dumb
hey I was thinking that after the show
maybe we could go do something just you
had kinda told Elliot but I'm my
criminally fun I'm in ok wait you forgot
your bag it's for you
just a little survival kit for your new
life on the lam
drive safe Chloe oh thank you enough
presence I gotta get in presence today
just saying doesn't pray very happy
hello jumpshot
[Music]
okay I remember this place this is why I
was trying to get in here already
because I was like you've got to be able
to get initially yeah my best friend
gave me a little Halloween thing give me
the 10 verse mystery bag there's me as
Sally
I died
yes I need those cheeks but she's
actually yet she's not going home is she
fair enough what let's do up this place
because later on this is where we take
max S&M I mean we got our name for a
second there you take max joyful build
in the junkyard and now I'm putting it
together so it's pretty cool
it's time to talk about the elephant in
the room nice elephant [ __ ] rules
nothing like an abandoned Shack in the
middle of a junkyard to make a girl feel
like exploring a new wardrobe you don't
even have them evidence matter how do
you know what it looks like in here
though this outfits bonus outfits
just on us
yeah
you see a bra no I'm like a weird way I
just like that is very promiscuous and
more girly than she used you I guess
he's a Rachel's clothes it makes sense
cowboy boots still the fifties Frank
when's clear we going to have blue hair
right in question like that day I'm Roy
did and hello max sup my jeans
and Cedric yes the full video will be
kept on my channel to the boy thank you
for coming Oh going up and down changing
no no it's completely the wall
so it was him sorry ingenious - doesn't
like each include if it's gonna be here
it will hide out okay let's figure out
what he wants because he did not sound
like a happy bunny oh that's the woman
we saw with Rachel's dad
weird okay so I think she's a druggie
it's Chloe
she don't know the secret password man
is the password drugs yes finally so you
know I can't wait for Resident Evil DLC
when are we gonna get that I think
there's a trailer for us she wasn't it
that's gonna be good dude it smells like
piss in here
shut up you have a rough night or
something every night's a rough night
maybe that woman's interesting go get it
for me would you geez man
get my notebook price is he driving why
is he driving here dude
no well Justin wait things for Frank how
low can I go sorry Frank
I didn't know it was your RV when I
wrote that
yeah gross
fight the power however to protect your
assets
yeah let's use the computer I guess wait
Frank got a puppy oh yeah Frank's real
doggie he's still paying everywhere
it's he's in the RV is my way smells
like piss
you have to stop scolding your puppies
Thanks then why share my accent bye we
have puppy requires patience if you
cannot kotori's our phase of DP honestly
or whether you're already able to have a
dog I said I don't scold him well
there's no need to swear I think it's
pretty clear now that you do scold her
you better not scold your dog
oh wait there's more Rachel the
therapist would have a field day with
this
[ __ ] the mill burned down one button
though shouldn't have I'm furious
everything's banned can't stop thinking
about it dog scent make it and the hot
dogs died
no that's 10k gone just like that and
you don't care about the dogs plus the
stud fees we had coming our F and the
Hulk for we're gonna be pissed
how am I supposed to come back for this
my reputation I can't think straight
oh I just want to find you saw the fire
and burn his face whatever the girl
though that's an expensive dog the dog
is special man carries by I wanted him
and I'm I am me I said f of three grand
I'm saving him for Frank I mean
everything you've done for me adds up
maybe we'll do gun don't thank me
three K this is from me to you just let
me bring him later why it's so special
about his dog man I hope
okay so Frank's a fellow survivor of
black health
so here's your buck well I wonder if he
was kicked out as well that dog food or
just beans beans beans more beans - for
the man who enjoyed a searing pain with
his drive-thru order I love hot sauce
that's an insane amount of beans a lot
of burning
oh good fruit eat I'm home got it why
should all freaking out that he's just
started driving off and she has no idea
where he's going everybody else he's
going his fridge then Frank must be
spending hundreds of dollars on this dog
why is it just for the companionship no
because he was scolding him part of a
balanced breakfast don't mind if I do
don't I even [ __ ] think about it yeah
he knows that okay I guess we're going
in here
it's the dog in there yes
hey there Papa do get up here pompidou
your little killer
what's this okay that's that look at my
messages
this is you're a nerd get it I heard you
guys but oh yeah Frank and the junkyard
Elliott oh yeah dude I'm fine
she's so blunt he's obviously just
worrying about her and she's like dude
I'm fine
pompidou went where'd he go where
doesn't know little Krueger cuz Frank
when they gave up on the steak his
feeding mistakes I guess I couldn't do
that Frank and his
that's adorable
why is no fit for Frank TBI I don't you
know I'm doing right now I'm just kind
of
look at this is
you just want to think it is glad I paid
that off
a hit list
yeah
drew still owes him over a thousand
dollars she's trying to find out what
Frank wants to discuss yeah oh my god
France got a knife swingy flippy
instrument of death you know what take
it just in case here never mind let's go
talk to Frank is this it have a seat
where's papa do you that's one badass
name it's French
he's so good does it mean like tough guy
or something
do I look like I speak [ __ ] French
okay so who was that woman what woman
the one I saw coming out of your RV oh
yeah I meant to introduce you her name
is mind your own [ __ ] business demand
Anantha let students know more I bet I
can convince Frank it's harmless to tell
me dude
I'm just curious what's the big deal
idiot I make money by being discreet
no [ __ ] Frank you think I don't know
about hiding things from other people
I'm a teenager come on price I got to
protect my clients happy customers are
the foundation of a good business why is
that one under last MERS like you cuz
you're laid-back
that's why I like you so you should keep
building up that easygoing vibe you know
sure I guess so why you so long that one
is a chick
come on Frank this is her Katie obey
gossip is all we have to keep us from
hanging ourselves out of boredom
I don't know Frank talk
I'll get my mom and make you something
special like what he had like wow your
house chili averse you got it
does she bring him food from hum-hum so
say him for his drugs showed up a few
weeks ago cousin all kinds of trouble
for all sorts of people like who it's a
little out of your league
okay but what kind of trouble exactly
get about it Chloe shouldn't open my
mouth oh I hate when people stop cutting
the story and I don't finish it whatever
you hear the Millburn down
yeah I heard some stuff about it
crazy my friend Damon runs the place he
lost a lot of money last night
yeah I read money from what I helped him
out wait someone don't drown me in the
detail spring lately he's been doing
some stuff that I don't like but I don't
seem to have much leverage with him like
a loser anyway yeah I have [ __ ] to
discuss I've got a little job for you
open my notebook last page hey catch me
violins thank you first join in the
stream no one drew north yeah oh [ __ ]
that's a lot of money
drew runs over 1,000 pound guy only
football players eat it like candy fat
smart I guess it pays well go big foots
problem is through owes a grant and he's
not answering my calls
you know what's going on with them
no no I never talk to him or his type no
one's just a type price anyway here's
the job taking you to Blackwell go to
Jerusalem find the money and I'll meet
you to pick it up can you handle that
what's in it for her of course but
what's in it for me I'll give you a 10%
cut of the money
yeah sure
I'll just 10% for literacy sneakers
handsome taking it it might be a little
tough I'm not supposed to be at
Blackwell my god expelled this morning
congratulations by Alexander still easy
and Maxis gains court life is strange
before the storm if you can't even do
this price $100 closer to leaving
Arcadia Bay with a bit of cash and the
truck fixed Rachel and I could really do
it looking a hundred dollars it's not
very much I'll do it
good
and he is driving her as if she's gonna
say yes I knew what if she said no hi
remember this it's their homes bruises
all over my legs you just go see The
Tempest anyway go go say hi to Bates
your mom and say hi Natalia and then
have that conversation about who are you
gonna hang out with afterwards I would
just try and hang out with faithful
that's just me try to be a people
pleaser hey Rita back at school yet
again they've got some tents up for
dressing rooms what do you got - I'm hit
- actually running an errand for my
dealer really so bad come see me when
you're done
yeah for sure I saw that one oh yeah
what panties just cause you're a lot of
people or something her name's zebra
Rachel I think maybe from knowing her
name oh my bad Kohi just keeps saying
things I see you soon and get into the
dorms why would I buy if I had enough
money to build a whole dorm probably not
a dorm finally sounds posit it looks
like food to me here during finals make
everybody jealous do they get free food
around finals I am freakin jealous later
biue this is a moment of calm
yes Aaron had cowboy boots
you can sing thanks max do you want to
see more missing and I have a playlist
could you just call me no of course it
wasn't you here this morning
stop being so dramatic Chloe gap right
just oh looks like someone got rejected
from the vortex love let's celebrate and
then from each other we are black
world's greatest resource what does that
little oh wait hey hey Steph
whoa hey barb that elf barbarian
surprised to see me on parole I told you
Wells was out to get you that text was a
rare courtesy by the way I don't
normally get involved in other people's
dumb decisions I was on you because I am
the ultimate lost cause skipping with
Rachel amber does have an appeal well
yeah so what are you doing here ah see
in the tempest you figured I'd see The
Tempest for real
you yeah I know it's not really my thing
kind of hoping it's a [ __ ] show what the
hell I'm the stage manager huh I think I
knew that my bad
nice honestly the show is really good
it's worth seeing I'm sure it is
obviously Rachel's fantastic but
everyone else is pretty impressive too
you get to see a totally different side
of everyone especially the guys
okay I'm intrigued I'm intrigued go on
like Hayden so annoying but when he puts
on that crown he's actually very
princely and maybe there's a Taliban
there's so much stuff there right Nathan
is dead a damaged boy yeah well good
luck with all of that maybe I'll see you
later hey I wanted to ask you something
don't play Dungeons & Dragons again I've
been planning to make a move on Rachel
but I know you're not if you two were
together oh good move so are you I mean
that's Rachel's business or maybe yours
and Rachel's business but if you feel
comfortable telling me you think we're
together I think we're together you've
been hanging out a lot which I know
might not mean anything but I like to be
extra careful about these things
I don't know I'm
I don't know it's it's confusing
I can imagine you ever want to talk to
me Chloe you know you can right I'll see
you later Steph have fun storming the
castle
yep I gotta get some money so see you
later okay there's I think so the
groundskeeper the one that loves the
squirrels yeah
Ivan subject for the day come better you
than me bird Blackwell Academy
conserving water since owners he's oh
it's that guy taking pitches what are
you doing here
aren't you supposed to be at home
thinking over your endless list of
questionable decisions hey TJ why do you
care about my questionable decisions it
offends me come here you actually see
the Wolves it's not like I messaged Eve
elegant damn straight
Wow yes miss travel to Fabrice really
ridiculous
I should know first you say well yeah
I'm confused um I wasn't listening
so let's smoke him hey Evan as
intelligent as you look right now you
can still see that bird from where I'm
standing I appreciate your concern but I
want to get this shot exactly right and
I've learned something about myself
recently with that I've learned that if
I'm passionate about something it's
probably the right thing to care about
for example I've been trying to get the
students and administration interested
in forest fire prevention that is kind
of an odd topic to focus on
people are so eager to pass on
responsibility to anyone else so that
they can live comfortable unworried and
ultimately meaningless lives
hello you see what happened no you're
right you were right sarcastic about
like that anyway you're not supposed to
be here now leave me alone
you go back to take take your peaceful
moment what's in here then I'll also
soon know I have the feeling it wasn't I
am here for drew him
oh no looking into that connection
most look at drew nor am I still here
only the athlete but he is more than
that
a technician that hurt he has with much
love and no room for fear I've always
thought he was kind of a bully he may be
that - no one is just one thing that's
true nature what do you think of Rachel
amber tell me your wisdom reach out
Rachel is a dragon made of diamonds
she's a bit dangerous then that's
dangerous with Pete sleep do you just
make this [ __ ] up on the fly or do you
like write it down beforehand
are you angry all the time because you
like the way it feels or is it merely a
desperate defense okay just stop
everyone intimacy getting bad internet
connection
ah yeah maybe because of both using the
Internet I'm talking to my housemate no
yeah maybe if if yeah I think so
I mean I'm probably gonna get off at
like 11 anyway
hmm oh I'm sorry guys thanks TJ maybe we
should like figure out a system just
every Wednesday I'm going to be
streaming and next Tuesday cuz it's
Halloween so yeah I'm gonna be doing
Tuesday next week but every Wednesday
night I'll be streaming my momma has it
gone better I don't know let me check
it's still bad
would you guys think does it gotten
better for you no I mean YouTube tells
me when it's got a good or a bad
connection so if it's bad
is connect I'm just gonna ask you to the
chat
for me it's not loud yet oh it's
probably only lightning for some people
what's apparently still about a it's a
good connection yes okay I'm happy
thank you let's carry on playing Somalia
so what about Elliott Hampton have you
seen him recently I only see what
Elliott wants me to see okay usually I
can see both what people want me to see
and what they want take you Elliott it's
like a mysterious guy he'd seen that
mysterious thing would you I want ya
hidden what what do I want to keep
hidden that you are lonely and afraid
dot dot dot
I think he's right it's okay not to be
okay Chloe price that's wise words I've
gotta go yeah it's been real
it has I often wonder what real is
farewell Chloe price
I like that guy even though he's a
little bit creepy is there anything to
your graffiti another what is the
housework Samuel oh oh it's so cute
that's what I miss girls such a nice
white door though it feels like it's
missing something doesn't it too bad I
can't tag it with Samuel standing right
there huh that's some intellectual [ __ ]
Samuel am I gonna have to like try and
get Samuel Samuel outside resident
creepy groundskeeper just so that I
couldn't AG that door yeah yeah I'm on
tight okay
okay I think I'm gonna have to turn on
this you shouldn't be on campus Chloe
can I still go up here to the turtles
room definitely isn't this well oh okay
but I need sun else ago and let's like
come back at a different point maybe
yeah that's great I'll do that okay
let's go to do his room
locked figures hey Stadion looks like my
options stumbled across mystery master
lock welcome or swipe someone's keys I
just feel bad taking her keys
my show by taking his keys but he's
really into this photography and he's
proper bent down so maybe I couldn't
take you shouldn't be on campus Chloe uh
maybe maybe she'll give me some keys
notebook
why yes Chloe of course you may look
through that Steph's really good at
creating fantasy worlds yeah not this
[ __ ] anyway sorry about that
Olsen a keys in fists right I was
getting here
what locked figures
looks like my options are it become a
master lock picker or swipe someone's
keys I mean I guess the grounds keep it
would have keys right how am I gonna get
keys though
[Music]
samuel resident creepy groundskeeper do
anything maybe I can get there now when
caused the destruction of something
Drew's room definitely isn't this way oh
and about the time-travel stuff I
honestly don't even realize that it's
gone so much Oh max would have jumped on
that photographer position me help us
get in the house
huh suna probably has keys to the dorms
yeah I know
abandon all hope Oh apparently the keys
are right on the table hell you
I am so observant but hey at least I got
this graffiti thing okay so let's go get
this keys thank you for letting me know
Wesker how do we not see them oh oh
right here go there if only those keys
master keys what Samuel working on the
sprinklers yeah so I tried to get you to
go and do something with them earlier
but obviously it wasn't the right time
still can't do something ever you be on
campus Chloe if Samuels working on the
sprinklers is some damage here might get
his attention
what evan is right there okay so I've
got to distract the bird sorry Evan I
hope you got your picture you've been
doing that for ages Hey [ __ ] I wanted
you to go the other way like as far as
possible the other way the totem pole oh
yeah thank you still uh okay let's go up
to the totem Drew's room definitely
isn't this way
maybe I just scary again yeah what are
the chances that 200 years ago some
teenager got in trouble for carving face
seats that is until seats over there so
I think I just gotta scare it hmm
time for a fresh start okay so I've got
a look the way that I want to scare the
bed I think so let's go this way here we
go okay now he's here now but way down
there over here
yes one small flight for this bird one
giant leap backward for Chloe price Oh
if I can scare that bird fall he must be
gang so angry
am I taking it to the totem pole I think
I am this way gotcha perfect
you're very welcome ever welcome okay
let's go do this
awesome now I just have to wait for
Samuel to turn on this that works
oh right he looks like a poor Samuel
giving you more work to do one all you
want to do is observe the students and
carve your little girls okay let's take
these keys
oh and well I'm here Oh
a school peace offering so cool
sorry about the bathroom that's so cute
he's gone oh not adorable
what was he doing here who would have
thought sprinklers would be the key to
getting inside the dorms all right sorry
Samuel massive keys that's good all
right time to find Drew's room no time
like the present
he was pretty chill about me like being
annoying with that bird
oh he's obviously a nice guy call me
tell me about my bruises why are they
here
hey skip uh-oh how's it going not that
it isn't great to see you and all but
what are you doing here
didn't you just get expelled ah ah ah
let's say I'm honest liquor my secret
drug-related mission skip when I'm
talking to the authority of the Arcadia
Bay district attorney's office really no
he says stupid I'm just visiting a
friend I can't I really can't just let
you go in
ok let's do a side dude you're just
gonna have to let this slide I don't
think I can in fact I think I have to
ask you to state your official business
or else fake Kate Blackwell property I
hate to do this to skip but I've got to
get inside maybe if I make him really
uncomfortable he'll feel guilty and let
me pass
maybe you can tempt him with your mom's
cooking official business
well men's business guys always get away
with that I've seen my uterus I need to
use the restroom
glad you asked what oh no it's my job to
ask Chloe
if you keep violating students personal
rights you're going to get fired so bad
it's not like that do you know what
wells would do to me if I didn't you
know patrol doesn't offend you Wells
doesn't really respect you right you're
just a a rent-a-cop who needs a haircut
I thought we were friends
where is this common father I thought we
were friends too but when the man comes
down on you you come down on me is that
it look look look I am really sorry
Chloe so confused right now
no this is not the other way around the
other way skip it's not like I'm up to
an open-air accused of looking my babes
that's weird room I don't know what to
do ah seriously my uterus is on fire
dude what is that descriptive enough you
know easy way to me I don't know what to
say I'm so sorry
she even neither's keys after all hey
nothing no me thank God oh I'm on it
I won't tell Wells do what you have to
do okay I won't tell anyone don't pee Oh
blessing is so sweet how's it going
we found it yeah they are coming after
you and your car but I'll be five
minutes it's been 20 yeah but I had to
get the keys
hurry up do me a favor I'm really
getting 10% of this there's $100 I was
like 80 pounds wasn't there that 85 it's
not very much
how's she gonna get in the room like
what if it's locked
she's left the keys out there
all right which one is Drew's room first
fire were the update I'm Katie obey for
us watch check the local media its
contained so they're slowly putting out
the fire
okay that's good okay good thou shalt
not have women if he tried Alex let's go
into you your friends room guy who
blatantly likes you and he loves science
too good match um Ellie its kind of
preppy in his own way maybe he does
belong at blackwell I knew Elliot did
well in class but I didn't realize he
was here on a full ride
getting to know him by some me bring
through his stuff it's what I do with
never been able to get to get to play
for me
I guess he's how they're really good or
Elliott's mom seems nice but your
scholarship your grandmother just said
of course he did he's my grandson after
your father caught again but July the
4th I told him it was too early to
decide you focus on school right now but
if you want to spend some time within
this summer of course I'll support you
don't break too many hearts over there
that's cute you do know you are a you
got English for dinner will bite what's
she like I think she's hot say something
cool about me to her he's our friend
Logan I don't think we know who Logan is
Thanks Warren Graham is such a Warren
Dewey
I'll grant you Edward make some awful
movies Edward made some awful movies but
so many even more suddenly terrible
movies came out after plan 9 from outer
space have you seen neither net produces
the space so he's compared to giant
carnivorous rabbits there's way less
porn here than I would have thought how
to tie a tie video Elliott Hampton
Arcadia Bay Chloe Elizabeth price Acadia
Bay Chloe Lilith price he's a little bit
obsessed I would say Chloe price hmm a
luminosity I'm meaning cool anyway let's
open this
what's in here huh Oh Mamba the show
crazy that Elliot would hold on to this
picture after so long he likes you howdy
is that not obvious when she left the
room it was electric flush wins tour
with a hey I see her in the
brick-and-mortar in the fresh cut grass
eyes flashing bright like coins the
ferryman can't have her I say but the
dark God is it that Elliot's writing
about that moment when the Sun is almost
there the sea so welcoming and warm when
poured light smoothes the nodding waves
when shapeless cold infinity confirm
conform someone start playing and for
one moment only all is possible all say
yes my heart says yes her eyes say yes
but I thought they see her but they
don't see her how is that so when all
the world is negative and dark and she
cries out a screaming rocket you are
about to die me how childish she is how
lovely and cruel have black knife
spelling words and Japan yeah well done
Chloe you finally realized how how did
you know this close up he won't ever
know he will never know I was never here
why is he just leave this door open like
this the world breaks everyone and
afterward summer strong at the broken
places why does that make me sad
he's a sensitive guy oh yeah it does
work really hard I guess I'm happy for
him okay time to leave I got his room
he's none of these whose room is this
break your leg whose room is this brain
decay but I'm Nathan Prescott nathan is
such a creep this is really gross orange
you glad I didn't say banana what okay
so it's obviously Nathan Prescott for
you ah great season mondo good luck at
state here we go this is what we need to
go yeah needs to talk definitely not a
news room to knock okay it's cool we can
go
you're so lucky that none of these
people lock their doors
just saying
oh god you like the game max it's really
good get the first one but the first one
throughs not here okay if I were drew
where would I hide my money hmm
let's just be nosy about drew for now
because I'm so much [ __ ] true a college
scholarship no wonder you're so into
football
I love how like athletics stuff like
football and things are so big in
America you can literally get full
college scholarships through it's crazy
so great we don't have really anything
like that here I don't think that the
dinner choices hope some of it is a
steak yeah that's no good for me I
didn't realize Drew was this good at
sports I bet he can't wait to get out of
Arcadia Bay you're a student athlete his
potential to make a powerful impact on
both our team and our student body as
the head coach I'm here to assist and
support you in your journey she looks
nice thank you so much for your
consideration the generous scholarship
offer I regret to inform you that I have
chosen to attend Oregon State in the
fall thanks for your time oh so he's
like Frank knows that he wanted him
looks like drew sells happy pills to his
fellow meatheads
oh yeah you saw me take that hit for you
last night right no one gets in my voice
girl on my watch but hit me up will you
some officer [ __ ] out of luck around
here at least Drew has some prospects
interesting
too bad I lost my release form I was
really looking forward to running all
those saw what he elapsed yeah
comic books Durga Ron come on I think
you saying that [ __ ] dead bad guys
don't usually look so obvious but yeah
dad's very cool I like I like it's got a
sleeping bag is that way he sleeps
someone's been sleeping on his huh
looks like Mikey's been staying here
with Drew oh maybe he's the one making
the gun books that's cool
Mikey's figures playing that game
yesterday was actually fun it is him
making the convicts see you die my books
makes you a cool person not football I
feel bad that I'm taking from his
brother now because I like him where
would I be if I was money oh man looks
like juice dad is having a hard time
done oh right
guess I have to crack a four-digit code
Oh buddy
yeah okay let's look around again I know
I just did but maybe eleven twenty
thirty six let's try this oh wait now
there's only four maybe not um it's
gonna be like oh maybe it's to do with
where's that numbers on here would Drew
really use something like this for a lot
combo I could try it it's just one two
one two one probably know though I don't
think this is right
damn it wrong numbers ah okay um oh oh
wait what's your under didn't look on
the counter
I wonder exactly how important 5:16 is
to Drew mmm 5:16 okay so I would like
she's like a little detective Oh fine
no.16 damnit
wrong numbers
I didn't realize Drew was this good at
sports any numbers that you can't wait
to get out of Arcadia Bay Frank wasn't
lying looks like so many folks are [ __ ]
out of luck around here at least Drew
has some prospects
holy [ __ ] drew a college scholarship no
wonder you're so into football I don't
know I am actually stumped
wait what are you saying spoiler warning
1/2 to 7 oh but why the waiters like
come from I want to know one two three
awesome
I don't know it's granted
done
but what's up friends this is kind of
fun which I can feel get lots
scholarship suits crazy people drove
beat you up too high Mohammed track pot
I'm kind of good at this should be a
detective
oh damn
hey LM on toilet what are you doing here
ah did you don't know that me two really
good friends looking for your brother
but he's not here
so why bro yesterday wasn't enough you
want to go another round doesn't matter
Mikey get your stuff let's move why are
they rushing off watch make you faster
that's cute
[ __ ] that's Frank's friend in the
picture right what's going on don't
worry about it stay in here and don't
say anything little brother whatever you
do don't open the door you know you
shouldn't have come here
schools not the place for this really
where is the place to collect my [ __ ]
money I told you I don't have it
cells are down man nobody wants to get
high right now but look it's preseason
we've just started to a days those are
gonna kill it I'll be able to sell all
the oxy you got drew you owe me a grand
where I said I don't have it right now
I heard about your dad's job by the way
tough time yeah better grand that's
pretty cool 180 mikasa ways I don't know
what you expect me to do I can't just
make money appear out of thin air
please just give me one week you're just
going to lie there I thought football
players just go out there give him his
money have to I can't stay in there
didn't realize these new friends of
Frank anyway right so Frank will
understand right
okay who the hell are you Frank sent me
to collect yeah that's what I meant
about the cutaways Frank was going on
about wait are you the [ __ ] who tuned
up Sheldon that guy at the mill oh yeah
he needed it
yeah he was an [ __ ] he kept harassing
me he needed to get the message
Frank was right about you let's see the
cash
we need that I bet most people did this
it's all here
Mikey you need to help your big brother
help him understand that I take this
[ __ ] seriously come on
Mikey's got nothing to do with this man
you helped your brother understand that
if he steals from me again I'm coming
back here and I'm going to break his
knees thanks kid
hello butter brothers entertainment we
needed that money you just screwed us
over
you were gonna get be Internet dad that
guy could have killed you you don't know
anything about this situation it's none
of your business
oh he see looks pretty huh I'm just
trying to help
I was trying to help Damon wasn't going
to stop until he had that money you
think you're some kind of hero no I mean
it for poor Nathan Prescott and now
you're messing with our lives
Mikey yeah I got a look at your arm just
leave us alone
I'm sorry look I'm sorry sorry doesn't
get our dad off the streets doesn't
Sachs we'll be okay
well that was sad I had no idea all that
was happening hmm
you're probably gonna go soon it's like
a a lot huh dissertation meeting
tomorrow I don't want to go to it huh no
I do I have to go I'm just like aa
dissertations may not even sure if I
like my question anymore that's the
better option what someone's like you
already have to up and then someone else
is like that's the better option so I
just dope what I felt was right and I
felt like I wanted to help well I just
can't I wouldn't be able to stand there
and watch someone get beaten up and know
that I had the money
ya know how did she miss the play has it
gone on yet was she first she's other
very eager or she's very late I think
she's eager
oh cool and behind-the-scenes
this day has been so messed up at least
I can talk to Rachel now if I can find
her back here let me have this any way
that I can help
Mikey's arm is broken Jerry told me a
little bit about what happened it's
really messed up okay at least she's not
blaming me
I don't think Mikey doesn't have h
alloys with fire Rachel + swords should
be fun
so mr. Keaton boy if it isn't the muse
of the blackwell drama department tell
me young lady
do you still believe true love is a lie
yeah definitely for sure the only person
you can trust in this world is yourself
everything else is just hormones and
fairytales
a cynics wisdom takes no prisoners
budding drama Church
may your propitious appearance count the
game Gingrich's sudden recusal an
emergency she says huh
word word Stephanie was our Lion of the
light board but platitude another the
show must sojourn forth that dude is
weird
oh wait just message me how's this super
long Aaron Garin yo crazy chef Enosh use
him like really bad you occasion you
talk about it yelling isn't why into the
show's over
I'm backstage great on my way sweet yeah
I'm just gonna no xenos after all the
work stuff did it's amazing that she
would drop everything to be there for my
heat oh yeah they're like best friends
right hey Hayden address me as Ferdinand
good lady nope
all right hey go [ __ ] yourself
super lame Chloe I mean super lame fair
maiden great huh method acting really
Thanks
what is she do she's been a Samantha Shh
Nathan please I can't do it dad I'm
sorry
keep your voice down listen to me
thanks for coming yanking my fan you
don't understand
they all hate me they're just gonna
laugh at me how do you suppose that is
I don't know because you show weakness
just like you're doing right now dad
when will you learn that this isn't
about you and your problems this is
about the Prescott name my name no
wonder he was such a douche in the first
game Nathan yes good now break a leg
I'll see you after the show
great pep talk mr. P everyone knows the
best way to instill confidence in
someone is by intimidating them I don't
know who you are
but mind your own business okay I am the
voice of reason don't you have like a
private bunker filled with gold coins
where you could have these conversations
nice evils nice evils you know coal I
feeling really bad for the guy even
though I know he wasn't a verdict but oh
nice angry
hey Nathan's dad is some [ __ ]
huh I know I wish I'd just don't let him
leave him alone she likes him doesn't
she
um Nathan's dad sucks but you should be
careful what you wish for when it comes
to parents Chloe I wasn't thinking
I'm sorry for what you didn't kill my
dad or did you though that was a joke no
your dark sense of humor reminds me a
lot of Nathan's actually the two of you
are really similar wait hell does that
mean I'm serious
you're both artistic and surprisingly
sensitive you've been through a lot and
a lot of people unfairly judge you for
it I think you stood up for Nathan
yesterday because you know what he's
going through
Nathan's hurt and he needs help but
whenever I try to help him it always
seems to make things worse if so you
want me to be what would you want me to
do oh I see um I don't know because I'm
very different Preston to Chloe
well the Chloe won this yeah you know
I'm super pissed the last thing I want
is someone trying to calm me down but
maybe it's what I need yeah Nathan
acted like he didn't want our help
yesterday but trust me he was glad we
did
Wow thanks Chloe that's actually super
helpful
yeah so he does need help even though
she doesn't say she does she hides away
but she wants you so let's shame
themselves another witty rebuttal by ABC
out should we go in here boys changing
tent oh thanks but no thanks
no way in hell I'm going up on that
stage okay so I think I've got to do the
lights right it's that thing that I'm
gonna do oh that I should find hey Dana
did Doug dig David's garden or did David
dig Doug's
did Doug dig oh I know he dug deep
David's garden or did David dig tunnels
I have not a thing did Rachel
oh that's not Rachel
what's she doing
she did
I need to find whatever Victoria slipped
into that drink oh I've got tax Oh Frank
price well sorted a price you did the
right thing ah today I feel bad
mm maybe I should give the money to them
there's only a hundred pounds though
what are these pills muscle relaxers
is that what she put in the tea hurry
now before your tea gets what are you
doing here
this area is forecast and I'm here to
save Rachel from the muscle relaxant to
try and sabotage the play like you
sabotage my homework I'm
Oh Rachel amber it was customary among
the thespians of ancient Greece for the
understudy to offer hot tea to the lead
actress on opening night as a way
appreciation for her tutelage it is in
that spirit that I offer you this
beverage may it help to reveal the
essence of your talents for all to see
oh my god she's so not Thanks
I'm gonna tell eat up Rachel I'm gonna
be honest is teeth how dare you Victoria
could this possibly be true of course a
dropout Chloe is clearly directing her
misplaced anger at me I'm sorry your
life isn't Oh No Chloe
Victoria is my friend she would never do
anything to sabotage me okay I'm really
sorry I just noticed that the stream is
really lucky wait until it gets better
okay tell you what
oh okay it's back to being good now
apparently really sorry about that
basically if he hadn't seen I mean he
said it was lucky but like if he hadn't
seen I told her about the the laxatives
cuz why wouldn't you tell her about the
legs like that we have no what's it
called
loyalties to Victoria I don't need to be
loyal to Victoria but I want to be loyal
to Rachel so yeah but the stream should
be okay now say I'm gonna carry on
playing sorry about that
and then she should drink the tea then
she can't prove it drink the tea wait I
wouldn't dance is integrity like that
then again if that's what it'll take to
convince you that Victoria is a good and
Carrie hey taco fine
come on Vic put drop out Chloe just tell
us the truth and for all uh-oh I'm gonna
make her go toilet onstage
oh oh I'm happy so happy oh whatever if
you're done accusing me of things I'll
just be on my way
[ __ ] Wow
saved my ass again
price all in a day's work and this has
been a particularly Patchett crazy day
life my dear young artists a misfortune
most unkind has befallen us Juliet is
waylaid that infernal inferno is the
culprit closing down the roads and
robbing us of our Ariel would that she
could but manifest on her master's whim
as a true spirit alas devoid of an
understudy the situation is a dire one
indeed I'm afraid we may have to cancel
truly we are a curse at lot
even my prodigious imagination cannot
conceive of a worse turn of fate way to
shake
and so your magic oh she couldn't make
me step in oh it's just gonna be like no
no he could step in for Juliet no
[ __ ] chance at least until the roads
cleared the cynic she's the right fit
for Juliet's costume she is indeed tell
me my dear have you ever acted before
yes no she's being modest we play improv
games all the time and she's fantastic
at it my dear what if I told you that
the entire fate of the production rests
upon your slender shoulders that's
pressure
Chloe please me well how can I say no to
those puppy-dog eyes she's awesome
I can't believe Rachel's talked me into
this you know cool you're freaking Raven
you look awesome
hey junk old junk dog jumbo climbing I
can't speak let my lines memorize all of
this by accident with strange
oh my gosh yeah good luck in like an
hour or something there is no way
wait here on my Ariel no yeah okay I'm
gonna try and memorize him just in case
I need to
all hail great what master I come -
he'll die best pleasure I boarded the
Kings ship in every cabin I flamed
amazement the fire and cracks of sofas
roaring there's another one not a soul
the chemists ever known
hell is empty and all the Devils are
here not a hair perished and as far as
me
is there more toil let me remember thee
what thou has promised my Liberty
that's my noble master that's my master
Elliott Elliott's gonna see me in the
show he's gonna be like where are you
Blake ah
change of plan kind of in the show now
it's like you'll see it's gonna be
hilarious let's have some tea no more
does it feel like stuff it's mocking me
from afar wait was that graffiti oh yes
it was when life gives you a lipstick
use it to tag [ __ ] tragedy did you let
her do the tragedy
that is good yeah happy with that yeah
she looks so cool I wish I had an outfit
like this looks like I'm late as usual
it's the time the only thing worse than
looking at spandex is being forced to
wear it you look awesome
I don't know what your problem is okay
right fine fine fine let's go let's do
this
hey needy active account that's an
interesting name we have there by
accident most strange bountiful fortune
hath mine enemies brought to this Shore
here see some more questions
thou art inclined to sleep tis a good
dullness and give it way I know thou
canst not choose come away servants come
[ __ ] my mind she must be so nervous
probably no schooi ready now okay
Bosley's listen say come dammit
no problem I've got this
I just want to Rachel What's My Line I
can't remember my line guys what was my
line oh okay I thought it had to
remember this I come to answer thou best
pleasure most furious now perform to
point The Tempest that I bade thee yea
the pointiest Tempest ever
I didn't I I boarded a ship right
hoarded the Kings ship
in every cabin I flamed amazement yeah
that was in the fire and cracks of
sulfurous roaring and make his bold
waves my brave spirit who was so firm so
constant that this coil would not infect
his room not a soul the Kingston
Ferdinand was the first man that how is
them day yeah empty all the Devils are
here Devils are here I think I'm getting
this right right yes yes hey Ariel see
alright I guess this is what I'm
supposed to walk somewhere oh [ __ ] where
do I want to ha guys I read this I was
just trying to learn my lines get the
ship okay wait I'm definitely supposed
to do some Oh Oh Chloe stand here okay
thanks Kat oh my gosh I am a mess okay
got a hair perished and as thou badest
me I have dispersed them about the aisle
in troops Ariel their charge exactly is
performance but there's more work is
there more toil yes let me remember thee
what thou hast promised how now what is
Val can't demand liberty right my
liberty indeed yes
thy Liberty nay this most of all I will
not grant that that's not her line is it
what's going on
but thou assured my freedom
didn't thou I never said how dearly I
hold thee my habits been to keep my soul
well draped most loyal spirit companion
and friend is acting in my service not
replete with the excitement amusement
and delight of course mistress most
truly it is so mr. key they're way off
script it's magical then why I pray you
wish you to be free
uh quick slam it isn't happiness
excitements a mere counterfeit of bliss
these storms and these adventures I
prefer to know thou still cared for my
plainest self like Heidi in my grass I
will not Bend
I will not see the flying forth alone
the envy would be more than I could bear
so come with me is that not in my power
spirit take my hands most faithful
friend for but a little longer I beseech
continue in thy service to my schemes
and when they are complete I swear to
thee we shall fly beyond this Isle the
corners of the world are mere prologue
I'll seek to make thy happiness so great
that in the name of liberties forgot
what says them to my most hopeful wish
haha so cringe your duty done for now so
go forth hence with haste I've worked to
do you crushed it good
you're a born best be in my dear I'll be
chasing you down next year and the
ending absolutely transformative I am a
humble thanks what the hell just
happened
shake it off
come on we'll visit Caliban my slave tis
a villain sir I do not love to look on
he does make our fire fetch in our wood
what ho slave
Caliban come forth donation girl is it
we could do as my mother
brush with Ravens feather from
unwholesome bed drop on you oh hey
Southwest blow on ye and blister you all
over
thou poisonous slave got by the devil
himself filth as thou art I have lodged
thee in mine own cell till thou didst
seek to violate the honor of my child oh
ho oh ho would it had been done thou
didst prevent me I had people else this
Isle with Caliban that just in fuel and
be quick so slave hence
[Music]
where should this music be in the air or
the earth
this play is super intense what is it a
spirit it carries a brave form tastes a
spirit know wench
it eats and sleeps and hath such senses
as we have I will resist such
entertainment put thy sword up traitor
do you love me o heaven o earth bear
witness to this sound I beyond all limit
of what else in the world do love prize
his tears run down his beard like
winters drops from eaves of reeds go
release them Ariel my charms I'll break
their senses I'll restore and they shall
be themselves now my charms are all
overthrown and what strength I have mine
own prey release me from my bands with
the help of your Bravo enough for this
game just put like random moments like
this in there just really think about
what it would be like to be unique just
living in everyday life they just put in
random things like the whole dragons and
dungeons skin I enjoy
dragging the gender seven James
you can only see the spot if you help
Nathan that's a button and encourage
Samantha to help Nathan
Billie huh wasn't that fun you're so
dead yeah
[Music]
more claps all claps you best be
clapping - where's Elliot why is she
there what are you doing wait do you
think that's Rachel's real mom and
they've been having an affair for 18
years now that's a bit spit out of there
isn't it and they were definitely
kissing so it's not like maybe it's a
long-lost sister or something mmm Oh
that'd be gross but I mean why would she
be watching the play maybe it's like an
old lover come back to town
[Music]
anyway he was [ __ ] himself
[Music]
that is
[Music]
my supposed amazing
My dear what if I told you that the
entire fate of our production rests upon
your the lenders
[Music]
I never had an experience like that on
stage right you know you like seriously
I love nights after a show is it always
like this
Oh totally it's such a high no more
nerves just the adrenaline so
first-timer are you proud of yourself
you were literally perfect to me I was
blown away I didn't try I try and
memorize those lines I think I'm just
happy it's over the last 12 hours have
been freakin tense
you've gone through so much [ __ ] today
right now it's pretty good okay no the
whole show was good I admit it
yeah it was magical
city's sweet or holding hand lets the
soda hand
I'm that she's such an awkward bunny
when it comes to romance
it's too quiet now okay for real for
real
do it no I've been thinking about that
all day but I can tell you yeah but like
eventually let's go now didn't we
already agree on stage we can't just why
not yes probably a lot of things like
money what about money parents I gave
the money collected the money Frank
wanted but then I gave it to that
[ __ ] Damon so I didn't get a cut like
Frank promised you did what you had to
do to keep true safe so that whole
situation was so messed up anyway
I've got more than enough to start us
out I always get birthday money for my
dad
how much everybody get hush money
I mean why did she told us anything yet
I know her parents have been shitty but
we can't just leave them my mom needs me
yeah the only one my mom has left you're
right what am I saying
she's got David now she did tell you
that she needed to possibly get without
a car I was just seeing if I could well
maybe it's not like I do this all the
time you'll figure it out but you don't
even know what shape it's in I don't
need to because I know you in other
words we've got transportation covered
she's taking of this like spa he's like
what hmm she's just pretty mini please
leave I'm not mean she's fine
you tell him I don't know if she was
Asian this Chloe price then I guess she
hasn't ridden manipulates it doesn't as
a story she doesn't money told us
anything like definitely long road trip
that sounds like the greatest idea
anyone ever
and driving down the coast that's why I
would choose a park if I was to run away
I wouldn't actually have a destination
in mind I would let you just think about
driving forever and one day you'll be at
a gas station fixing the brakes sorry
you guys let me see Los Angeles she's me
you're full of [ __ ] feel like
everything's possible Rachel stop if you
don't mean this
it's it's just making me feel like [ __ ]
that this life you're describing isn't
going to happen
[ __ ] sake I've never been more serious
in my life I want to run away take me
would it take to convince you
I see give me a promise in ink
no for me like pay for me and sassy not
like no no I tattoo on you oh I feel
like [ __ ] now I chose the wrong decision
I'm in my one favorite era see for me no
this is temporary the deal is no I
didn't think that I'll believe you I
just wanted to touch it dammit I said
let's leave tonight really
what does this ash isn't
I don't know if I'm nature's already bad
choice so what do you think oh well I'm
not gonna go back now let's go speak
some clothes and stuff for my house and
then oh my oh it's already bad now
[Music]
why was it such a bad choice
ask where is it again I mean should I
reload oh just because you want them to
make out I'm not making them make out
makes me feel awkward I don't want
people kissing on screen it's a key I
would have chosen the other one what was
the other one
it was the tattoo make out or kiss Oh
her bracelet no I'm fine
following my choice
he around her mom's house or her house
with a moment exactly Colin I'm not good
with romance
it took two romantic scenes Rose
Rachel's home
and she brought her new friend oh this
is so good
oh no our starboard you're just in time
dinner's almost ready Chloe was it it is
nailed it I must have been pretty
memorable I get the sense that you're
using an American Rachel honey you were
resplendent tonight thanks Chloe
you must join us for dinner tonight
uh-huh she must I must
oh yes some female chicken ala King I'm
for Jamal both acted up quite the
appetite
I'm not hungry yeah no thanks I'm more
of a Burger King kind of cow
she's funny this one I'm aware Chloe I
know we didn't exactly meet each other
at our best this morning but with you
and Rachel becoming such fast friends I
insist you join us for dinner
don't you agree Rachel yes of course
Chloe would you join us for dinner I
have to I asked you okay of course I
mean the parents already
oh you haven't even kissed yet then I'll
be right down
don't be long in the meantime perhaps
you can help me with the table alone
sure thing mrs. amber okay I'm gonna go
pack after dinner we can make a break
you cool down here please hurry back
just hurry back I don't know how long I
can keep this up
try doing it your whole life and Chloe
we just need to make it through dinner
try not to say anything that you know
that I would normally say exactly just
some quality time with me okay so how
long do I have left because I need to go
very soon I'm gonna pop to the loo but
then if you could let me know in the
comments I've been great but it's
nothing I probably can stop it here
maybe carry on
but anyway
[Music]
time to set the table I guess
okay what did you say
I really like 15 minutes like 20 minutes
a.m. okay then
it's understanding some before I knew
were unromantic or something it's not
that I'm uncool
let's finish this one
yo James hiya mister Amber Chloe what
can I do for you
your daughter's pretty great thank you
we were fond of her as well you ever
feel like she's so awesome at everything
that you just wanna shake her I mean
either so you're a district attorney huh
I'm your district attorney so I can call
you if I'm ever district arrested
what would you be arrested for stop
talking Chloe not a good one clearly
what do you think I thought Rachael was
perfectly cast she certainly was we're
very proud of her I had no idea they
were going to do that you I don't know
the name for it reverse casting casting
a woman as a man oh I just meant the
wizard part
I suppose that's also true
duty calls Hey good chat mister amber
mm-hmm
okay mm-hmm
doing the play was bad enough without
having to read about it afterwards
hope my keys okay sorry
oh yeah you're covering this isn't the
place to discuss text if you wanna talk
hmmm how to clear browser history how to
mean by the NATO Channel I love
yesterday that's like cheating asshat
101 porn Rachel wait that's a penalty
can I talk to him about it no duty calls
good chat mister amber mmm-hmm no
obviously I talked to Rachel about
Turner BAM holy [ __ ]
that's the guy who attacked drew I'm
glad I gave him the cash whew yeah he is
suspected of murder and everything I
guess some families actually go to Paris
instead of just talk about it their
whole lives oh yeah they had that
savings thought didn't they easy to see
who wears the literary pants around here
naked huh Rachel really wasn't over
achiever before she met me go out on it
that in the bud
I should see my graffiti on that yeah at
least send me that
oh yeah mr. ambassador with a suit and
tireless trip to Paris derp derp derp
derp derp derp something about this
photo doesn't seem right I should fix it
what do you mean you should fix it yeah
tag best of all Rachel's mom is right
there
she totally bust me no she's just
constantly thinking like what can I do
file today what can I do file I should
probably talk time on Preston Co
skeletons
lots of shiny dishes though to root hey
play sorry about what I said you only
trying to help
thank you that's nice no way I'm sorry I
had no idea what to do that was so
[ __ ] so right my kiss of I am i right
also eases thanks tell him I said hey
will do oh that's good um this heard you
were the template you're in the tempest
yeah is kind of Evita I believe that
everyone says the show is awesome you
get mad also - good day today Mikey so
kg will text you an update in a bit tell
them both pulling up that's cute okay so
let's PT hey there mrs. Amber Chloe I'm
so glad you're joining us tonight
ah Rachel
so Rachel was pretty awesome tonight
yes she was though to be fair she's
pretty awesome every night I wish I were
half as driven when I was her age me too
I get the sense that you're a force of
nature yourself I can see why the two of
you get along so well you can because it
still seems crazy to me yeah what did
you think of the play Rachel was
typically amazing but I never liked The
Tempest what did you think of it to be
honest I only really read a couple pages
feeders not really my thing I guess I'm
not so into saying words someone else
came up with
FairPoint then again I'm not sure you
can judge the entire art form based on
the dead white men your curriculum
focuses on shotsfired Shakespeare
integrity honesty loyalty what it's on
your lawn oh right sorry
I guess I'm still getting used to being
an elected officials wife much like
being married to anyone else I imagine
but with a lot more secrets right
secrets like attorney-client privilege
and all that well as District Attorney
he brings cases against criminals on
behalf of the state
he doesn't defend them of course not
that's setting the table finally putting
me to work or what yes if you could
please take four plates from the
cupboard and set them on the table what
if I can't
excuse me you said if I could never mind
Chloe she's so bright
stop hurry all right Chloe you've set
the table without ruining someone's
marriage before peace okay okay but we
know where the plates are it's off to
the table with you well done
plates achieved but they're now gone
from your hands let's put them on the
table
she's surprised us I'm just like yeah
look at this table it's wonderful this
is my masterpiece oh I think that's an
original who gives a [ __ ]
wonder if this is a family heirloom
oh yeah sure let's get some glasses out
glasses damn neat members are fancy as
[ __ ] I need to check out my mom Oh was
this so a just somebody in since mom
just called me were you in the place
tonight I would have liked to see that
kind of just happened and now it's last
minute I'm glad you're doing well it
would be nice to see you tonight coming
home he's going oh that [ __ ] makes me
feel really really bad
Oh texture mom bought Chloe I mean
that's so sweet that she was like oh you
were in the plane I would have like
never know you're listening drunk could
be so complicated
bless her I need to get this woman out
of the way so I can tag sort of it
family photo Rachel and I both had great
childhoods mine just ended a little
before hers I guess
now what do I do yes Chloe
lates
check anything else actually could you
be a dear and ask mr. amber what he'd
like to drink with dinner I will be a
dear mr. amber what are you drinking
something else what's your vice mr.
amber I'm sorry your wife wants to know
what kind of drink you're having ah
let's say sherry okay one two three
sherry comical Chloe maybe you can help
me understand something
Oh give it a shot Rosanna I we're
worried about Rachel
yesterday was so unlike her what do you
suppose is going on
Oh should I be honest here subscribe to
say maybe she's rebelling against
something or someone
what would Rachel have to rebel against
we've given her everything she could ask
for yet I'm not sure I buy the narrative
you laid out this morning in the
principal's office rachel is not known
for following along with anything she
doesn't want to I'd be lying if I said I
didn't have concerns about your
friendship but perhaps you're exactly
who Rachel needs right now is she
navigates the choppy waters of
adolescence
thanks thanks okay he wants whiskey
I know I'm gonna say that did you do
today digit yes Chloe sherry the glass
man like your sherry thank you
the glasses are in the china cabinet I
know I've already is in the city how am
I supposed to get to China kidding
it's the fancy looking cabinet right you
got it
it's the triangle shape one basic shapes
now you're speaking my language
cool where is it
okay so I'll put it wherever he's
sitting so I got two chairs
Oh head of the table obviously
by TJ but see you like verse cuz you
live with me uh now what is next
mother yeah Amber's what else feel like
I'm getting good at nothin [ __ ] only one
last step as our guest you may do the
honor of lighting the candles I seen
that Connie was in this cool I've got my
own Oh
you never know when you'll need to light
a candle great you are a paragon of
preparedness Thanks
hey think time to light some candles and
bless this joint up a bit know these
kind of
the amber family and fire what could
possibly go wrong
well this is a little Tony are you and
Rachel in any of the same classes um I
wish Rachel's all honors I'm still
trying to get into remedial what's it
called vocabulary what about that fire
dinner's really good mom thank you
Rachel
the way that fire spreads so fast I've
never heard of anything like it it's
almost surreal they say a fire like that
could only come from a crime of passion
passion what does that mean I don't know
you tell me cuz you're the DA of course
Oh Chloe is so bad I give you a mouth
shut I'm the Commissioner's Office
suggest sarsen arson why would anyone do
that any number of reasons with
everything going on in the world today
even a town like Arcadia Bay is an
immune to the ills of society I cannot
imagine how difficult these last few
years have been for you Chloe now that
you and Rachel have become friends I
want you to know that our home is always
open to you they seem very nice like why
is Rachel wanting to run away well said
dear I mean I she's a day at times we
remember what is most important to us
family families not merely a gift it is
a response I mean I know that he's
cheesy
ouch those we love must be cared for and
never ever taken for granted
okay let's do this
Rachel me don't Chloe I don't Chloe I'm
going to turn his daughter and wife
against him at his own not sure I agree
James okay oh I thought you of all
people would be grateful for a family at
least says someone if you ask me
gratitude is just one more way
privileged people tell the unprivileged
that they should be happy with what they
have that is an excellent point Chloe we
must always be sensitive to the way our
privileges shape our perspectives well
said mom still there must be a mom she's
a decent person Elise I'm sure you agree
Chloe
when my mom's boyfriend talks about
responsibility it's always code for him
trying to control other people guess
that's why they teach it in the army
shut by and bam bam see this is why it's
so important to invite diverse voices to
converse with one another it's
absolutely so mom is so nice it's like
raised five highly stimulating since you
have answers for everything Chloe
perhaps you'd like to enlighten us with
some of your hard-earned wisdom about
the world sure I believe that we should
look closely at everyone especially the
people in power to see what secrets
they're hiding very well articulated
Chloe I am consistently impressed with
how politically aware your generation is
Chloe is an excellent articulator
excuse me dear but if this is what
passes for politically aware these days
we're in serious trouble
James that's unfair and you get too
close no I don't believe it is it seems
clear that these points Chloe is making
are merely veiled attacks on me yeah
you're getting defensive now
are you suggesting that I'm using some
sort of incognito mode where I can keep
my activities hidden that's crazy
don't worry mister as we know I can tell
that my progressive attitude is not
welcome in this house I'll see myself
out James Chloe is right you owe her an
apology I owe her no such thing she
willfully acting belligerently just the
shadow of that salad bowl is crazy
reversing people like her
so we're profiling now this is what
eight months in the DA's office has
taught you I resent that my office is
committed to fair and equitable
treatment yes I've read the press
releases excuse me
are you calling me a hypocrite huh
Rachel I can't sit here and listen to
this [ __ ] and Rachel stop it dad
you're a hypocrite okay I know you lying
cheating piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
excuse me hmm
we saw you yesterday at the overlook
James kissing that woman James Rachel
idea honey whatever you saw or think you
saw I know it's hard but I need you to
trust me
think this we saw are you trying to
Gaslight us there's no thinking involved
we saw you locking lips with some other
woman this part is she and I used the
same drug dealer that's enough
you are not welcome here around my
daughter any longer I know exactly what
kind of person you are from the moment I
saw you and I let my wife's compassion
get the better of Oh
what kind of person is Linkwood a broken
girl from a broken home
that's enough James I will not have you
continue she's gonna see something with
the fire again
the slaves are getting bigger
Oh tell me the [ __ ] truth stop lying
stop being a politician for one [ __ ]
minute can't you just be my dad Rachel
that woman you saw that wasn't my
mistress that I knew it I called it
[Music]
[Music]
our minds are troubled by the emptiness
[Music]
destroy the middle it's away from the
start to the finish and if you're still
[Music]
starving
[Music]
come on so Victoria that was to be used
you did that to yourself
[Music]
sorry
I know
[Music]
Wow that girl look in the first games
because most easy she could have made
some nice
[Music]
did you start freaking knew that you are
a mom
[Music]
[Music]
is that it is there another scene
guys I didn't cry though tell me I was
gonna cry Nedim cry hey Tom I'm this
once again thanks for coming
I think I'm afraid the first episode
better just because it was like getting
to know Rachel kind of revisiting
Arcadia Bay again and I like the
portrayal of I like the little scenes
where she gets back together with her
dad and I know there was that
marshmallow one but they didn't make as
much sense as the scenes than the first
episode I don't feel and also this is
kind of debunked to any theory that
rachel has a superpower I think I don't
know there's still a third episode but
to me it hasn't really fell into that it
hasn't fed into that Rachel as a
superpower because people were
conspiring saying that you can control
fire and that she was the reason why or
the fire when it blaze I'm not sure I
mean obviously it was her fault she
keeps the bin and whatever but people
were saying that she was as she screamed
the blaze got bigger because she was
doing that but I don't know this this
episode just didn't really put any of
those theories in concrete so
but yeah I freaking knew it was her mom
I knew it I called it so what did I say
but I mean her dad is still being a dick
because he's with the other lady which
is obviously supposed to be her mom or
you know whatever and he's seeing her
biological mom behind her back and not
telling her that's still massively
douche move so yeah I'm so glad that
Khloe called him out on all that but
let's have a look what we did you took
the blame for Rachel 79% of course
everyone's gonna want to take the blame
for Rachel of course we'll do that for
her of course
you emptied your pocket to the Davies
request yeah because I thought that I
didn't have any drugs and 62% people
probably thought the same because she
went to go and get that joint and the
joint wasn't there so I figured hey I
have nothing on me I guess I
underestimated Chloe so sorry about that
Chloe um I gave Damon the money and most
people didn't and they stayed oh okay
well I didn't see that coming to be
honest and I asked for a tattoo and I
don't know what these I think that's 14
percent of people 73 percent went for
the kiss of 13 percent went for the
bracelet I just I just I just I guess
would be cool but I'd be like this I'm
like a kid when it comes
I can't watch like romantic movies it's
nothing yeah friend stats oh there were
few sent their pockets
Oh what's this
you didn't talk to Elliot about the play
oh where was he
I didn't see him oh when I said okay
okay um you're great star over 76
percent did that you didn't put the
singing man on the dashboard of the
truck damn it
let's see that you didn't pay off your
debt to Frank you didn't tell staff that
Rachel was single eighty-four percent
yeah it's like I don't know I'm gonna
keep that door open just a little bit
just in case you didn't return
Drew's money to him you didn't something
I don't know what this is you con
haunted Victoria before the play yeah a
lot of people didn't do that you tell
Rachel you'd like to go on a very trip
43 % people said about Los Angeles I
guess it does go in the storyline but
you know and you attack James
Oh unless people didn't do that Oh fair
enough
anyway that is the end of the game I'm
freakin a canal so thank you very much
for coming I hope you enjoyed and don't
forget to join me here I don't really
know what time but if you follow me on
Twitter
YAG Man X everywhere I will let you know
what time probably about 8 or 9 p.m. BST
I would playing the evil within - for
Halloween with two girls that I develop
games with and if you want to see the
latest game that we developed which was
the product of last year's computer game
arts course do head over to my second
channel which is gaming with the admin
expert trailer 1 up and soon there will
be another video on yog monix
where I'll be showing the trailer and
all
me rambling about it where you can buy
it and how it was and stuff so that will
be a thing that we have very soon but
anyway thank you so much I'm gonna try
and do more live streams and stop making
it a big deal and just start having fun
with it so do look forward to seeing
more of me hopefully and wish me good
luck for my dissertation meeting
tomorrow because I am underprepared I
think I did spend stay on it but yeah
I'm just not sure how I feel about um
but we'll see we'll see that's not to
the end of the day and I've got some
coding to do beforehand and I can't like
coding so that's not too bad anyway
we'll just say goodbye to you guys
individually the ones that I can see
anyway sorry if I miss you though
so goodbye Wesker goodbye slinky goodbye
mr. t later good bye Chris good bye
entropy empathy
goodbye Wesker Albert good bye mr. C
Leighton goodbye yeah I think that's
everyone I can see see you in the evil
within - yes actually I will put because
I I'm so I'm so proud of my little my
little gamey thang I'm just going to
I'm gonna leave this here with you guys
so if you want to check out the game
that is now on the Google Play Store you
can check out the little trailer that
I've done I've just pops it in the chat
for you to see and that does have a link
to the game in the description it's a
sleep paralysis simulation so it's
supposed to simulate sleep paralysis
which I do get quite often and another
one of the developers got it as well and
we did some research what I did a lot of
research so I'm I'm very happy but and
we're making another horror game and
this next horror game actually is on PC
so hopefully more of you guys can play
it we keeping a PC and because if PC you
should look nicer as well because you
won't have to worry about all the
restrictions are come for developing
with my well especially mobile VR and
cardboard because you want to make sure
it's running well some people don't feel
sick but anyway I'm just rambling now
yes thank you very much this dream good
night James oh and Michael and justice
as well because I don't think I said
your names earlier so yeah have a lovely
day or evening thank you again for
joining me tonight and I will see you on
Tuesday hopefully yeah have a lovely day
or evening I'm gonna awkwardly awkwardly
stop the stream now ba ba ba ba ba ba ba
ba ba ba baby Bell